[Music]
late stage trials of one potential
coronavirus vaccine are resuming in at
least two countries
after they were put on hold when a
participant developed symptoms of a rare
neurological disorder
the oxford astrazeneca vaccine is one of
the leading candidates in clinical tests
dr ashish jaws dean of brown university
school of public health
he joins us from providence rhode island
to discuss good to see you dr zha
and congratulations it seems like you
have a new position two weeks ago you
were at harvard now you're at brown
we know you're in high demand we're glad
you're here with us this morning
really good to see you good morning good
morning thank you for having me on
so it was put on hold over i mean it's
resuming overseas it's still on hold
here
do you read anything to that about why
it's not why isn't it resumed here in
this country
yeah so um thank you again for having me
on you know this is
confusing and one of the things that's
not been clear is exactly what happened
that caused the pause and why things
have resumed and i think it's really
important
for astrazeneca and the researchers to
be very transparent with the people of
the united states of great britain of
everybody
about exactly what happened so we can
all have more confidence in the process
because we all we all are very nervous
everybody wants a vaccine but we want it
to be safe and it seems to be such a
political hot potato why do you think
it's so important that they are
transparent let us know all the details
and why wouldn't they let us know the
details
yeah so first of all absolutely we're
all anxious for a vaccine i'm anxious
for a vaccine we all want one but we
need it for it we need for it to be safe
and effective
you know in general with no under normal
times
all this stuff is not always disclosed
it is eventually disclosed to the fda
but these are not normal times
and therefore given how much attention
we're all paying
i think it's critical for the
investigators to make all of this stuff
completely public
dr shah the ceo of pfizer who was on
face the nation yesterday said there's
more than a 60
chance the company will know by the end
of october
whether its vaccine works what do you
make of that and what could that mean
yeah so i've been really optimistic
about a timeline that we will have
vaccines that are found to be safe and
effective this fall
but we don't know what is motivating him
to say that i think again one of the
things that i have called for and others
have called for
is that these vaccine manufacturers
should absolutely
make their protocols and their research
and their statistical plans
all public so we can understand what's
motivating him to say that what's
underlying that assessment and without
that it's very difficult dr john if
if that does happen though if if we get
a successful vaccine by the fall how
long would it be
before people actually get vaccinated
yeah
so if you think about it we're going to
have to make hundreds of millions of
doses now some of those already being
made
but even after we have got them made
it's going to take many months to
distribute them
you know i always say vaccines don't
save lives vaccinations do and it will
take
us well into 2021 before a majority of
americans get a vaccine
you know the president said we have
rounded a corner on this corona virus
that's one school of thought dr anthony
fauci
says listen we may not be back to normal
to the end of next year
where do you stand what are your
thoughts
yeah so i unfortunately agree with dr
fauci on this
um where we have not rounded a corner i
think we're going to have some very hard
months ahead
i do believe 2021 will be better and by
spring to summer of 21
i think life will be meaningfully better
in many parts of the country
uh but we still have many months to go
and i'm worried that if we you know sort
of take our eye off the prize
we can end up seeing a lot of infections
and what do you need to see to let
people know that
it's okay to take the vaccine what do
you want to see
yeah i want to see data and i want to
see data on both effectiveness
and i want to see large enough people a
number of people in the trials and a
diverse enough number of people
before i know that it's safe for me my
family my elderly parents
and what i would recommend to others so
we really have to see the evidence and
data before we make a decision about
whether it's safe and effective
all right dr john thank you we'll be in
touch really good to have you here today